all right
mike and tina yeah my container
where you guys from originally i'm from
boston
i'm from missouri you guys met how long
ago
back uh three years ago yeah almost
mike tell me about your childhood in
boston
my whole family is from there
my dad passed away when i was five and
um since then it's been going back there
in the summer times it was going back
there in the summer times to see my uh
grandparents to live with them for the
summers so you lost your dad early
yep yep how was your childhood um it was
good
it was good but it was two separate
families it was my dad's side and then
my mom's side and um
both sides drank and uh just one side
was like
completely different than the other one
played cards and like they worked at
boston university
and like um they were in a union and
like i don't know they just seemed
different than
the the my mom's side and uh i just
remember
remembering that difference and um
sometimes it was a little harder to be
around my mom's side of the family for
some reason
not much harder but just different in an
uncomfortable way
but how would you describe your
childhood um
it was it was um
a lot of trying to fit in like like just
trying to fit in a lot i felt i felt
like i was misplaced
no serious abuse or no no no serious
abuse just my mom drinking
like um it wasn't and it when she got
drunk it wasn't bad
until like they would fight so my
stepdad who she remarried
would fight with my mom um and then once
they fought
it was like just a bunch of stuff and it
usually would end up with my mom saying
i'm leaving i'm going to go kill myself
which is ironic because i said a lot too
and um
and she would leave the house and like
i don't know i remember my mom like not
coming back one time and uh
like my little brother um
and i were looking out the window
and like wondering if if she was gonna
come home
like she said she was gonna kill herself
how old were you ah probably about
12 or something or something like that
maybe 10.
that's gonna be hard to it's gonna be
hard for a young man to deal with
yeah that's right it was hard
because i didn't really like um
i didn't think about it a lot until like
it was just me and my brother and i was
thinking about like
i don't know i just picture us looking
out through our nails
and uh then my mom like uh we moved
around a lot in virginia beach that's
where they separated my stepdad
and my mom and um that's where uh
we stopped moving or stayed to state and
um
i graduated high school there and um
you know i just tried to st i did a lot
of uh
staying away from home like just just uh
it was basketball mostly
a skateboarding um but mostly basketball
and um because i broke fractured my
wrist twice doing
a skateboard
what kind of jobs have you had um well
i've had mostly waiting tables jobs to
be honest
um i've been in the military i was in
the army i went off to vcu
like barely made it into college for art
for art
and um the drawing was like my
medium and um so but
i i got kicked out of the dorms for weed
and then
um yeah getting caught with the bong and
then so that led to me
joining the military because the guy
said he could beat my lead charge
and i was like cool i need some
discipline
and everybody told me not to go and um
but i'm the type that doesn't listen to
that and and just goes
and um so i went on a delayed entry and
got kicked out of that too i rebelled
but then i don't know i got to like out
of boot camp
and into the ait in maryland aberdeen
proving grounds and then i
got kicked out and sold weed for a while
like for a long time
and um got pretty good at that like my
life was like a movie during that time
and um and then you know everybody
wanted to do
cocaine and things like that so i didn't
really i was scared of the time that was
attached to it so i started waiting
tables and i'm
trying to get sober and that's when
and tina tell me about your your life
you grew up
where uh in missouri and how was your
family
um grew up poor but i didn't really know
it we were um
it was my mom and dad they're still
married to this day and then i have two
brothers
older one older one younger um
but very happy childhood
nothing too traumatic happen um
i just remember my parents struggling
you know and working a lot so i spent a
lot of time with my brothers
um but
i can't really say that i had any
similar experiences in my childhood like
anything
like he went through what kind of work
have you done
um i'm a registered nurse so out of
high school i went straight into college
and then um
nursing school graduated nursing school
and then i have just worked in the
nursing field for the past
since 2004
but
[Music]
i don't know i don't i started out in a
burn unit instance of care so
i loved doing that
later on i was working with like elderly
people
people who had behavioral health issues
mental health issues
and up until a few years ago i had
gotten a job i was an overnight manager
so i did the hiring firing
medicare medicaid compliance stuff like
that
um which was a lot more my speed but
um i had a pretty
pretty typical i guess walton's
childhood you know
and drugs came into the picture when for
you guys um
for me it came in um i think i did
acid first and that was probably i was
in high school
um on the weekend i did i did ask at one
time and um
i loved it secretly but like i knew my
mom was a drinker so
and i promised myself i would never i
would never become like my mom
and then um i promised myself that i
would i would um
if i had a son then i'd always be there
for him and uh
you know drugs drugs took care of
making those things really difficult to
do you guys have kids
yes i have a son sebastian and um
and who's taking care of him that's why
i'm in california um
his mom and god and his and her mom
she's from russia so she's here in la
county and
so you can visit him sometimes yeah
that's what we're trying to do i've been
i've been in california for a while and
like the the
um i've been distracted very very
uh forcefully and at times
not that i need it personally like it
doesn't take much for me to out distract
myself
honestly um but i've been so i've been
to california for a long time and
haven't
this time haven't seen my son for almost
a year now
but it was six years five years before
that and tina do you have kids
i have two kids um i have a son and a
daughter
and they're both back we met in virginia
beach actually
um and they're still in virginia beach
with their father
who is my high school sweetheart and we
had divorced shortly before i met mike
um but
they're a little bit older but um
they're still out there but you raised
them for a big good part of their lives
yeah i was a stay-at-home mom for a
little while you know um
am i
my ex-husband was gone a lot so it was
just me and the kids
um
probably 90 percent of the time thank
you
um and i had quit working
because my son had some special needs
and then uh
you know i just thought that i had the
perfect life for a long time
and then i found out on christmas eve
2016 that he had a
girlfriend on the side for a very long
time
and i'm not the kind of person who's
gonna take it take it you know so
that ended our marriage and i was okay
with that you know like
we were better friends than we were
husband and wife but
um i had been alone for so long
because i left you know all my family
back home
moved out to san diego with him for his
job
and kind of followed him around the
country
and uh didn't have any i don't talk a
lot
i like to talk about what's going on in
my life so
i uh started drinking and found that i
was able to
cope a lot better with uh all of a
sudden being a single parent of special
needs you know and
kid and i have to go back to work after
being out of work for a while
and i started drinking and drinking a
lot
and the next thing you knew i was
a year later closet drinking a
fifth of vodka five liter box of wine
as many beers as i could get a hold of
every day
um and ended up in the hospital for
about
14 15 days
um after i tried to kill myself
um
and so that
and then i had a dui during that time
that led me into aaa
which aaa led me to meet people who
introduced me to this
the world of drugs this world that i'm
living in now
and i had not even experienced that
until
i was 36 years old i guess so you're
living a very
straight life up until just recently
very recently i mean
the year before
i guess man 2017 i want to say i made
my you know tax return looked real good
you know and that i had done that on my
own and i had gotten myself
right up to six figures almost like i
had almost broken that barrier that was
by myself you know
and uh
that was when i was drinking heavy too
but i had never
i'd smoked weed once when i was 18.
and that was it that was my experience
with the world of drugs
um but then you know you
i get a dui the judge sentenced me to go
to a.a which i thought was a blessing
and i would still argue that it was you
know but um
those people introduced me to crystal
meth and
heroin and all the things that now have
become a part of my everyday life
[Music]
and here i am and you guys are living on
the street
yeah you're in skid row yes yeah we um
i i pretty much came in to i
i feel like this i feel like i came in i
i'm
those people that came in and introduced
her to those
drugs um she knew about him but
when we met in an aaa meeting and i mean
i don't like telling people that but i
tell people that because
it's kind of a unique thing and um it's
something to be
that warn you about in meetings and
things like that but um and i never have
done that
like ever i i was just coming out of
that relationship with olga
and um and you know that was five years
and we had sebastian
she was in the relationship for 13 years
and we've met that day and had like a
star wars shirt on with like a
c-3po or rt2 d2
whoever's a shorter one is r2d2
one of them this is the white one that's
short um not the gold tall one
uh i had that on my shirt and i remember
that and um
i remember her like being
like beautiful and but i was shy and i
didn't say nothing to her
and we talked after the meeting just
briefly and i
cut that short and dipped off and then
we ended up 12 stepping
my friend harry who was like relapsing
and um
and uh we brought him to the hospital
and she was the ride
some girl was like this girl was like
i'll bring him
i call my friend or whatever i'll give
you a ride and um she'll pick us up
and we'll take harry to the hospital and
harry had like puke all over him and
stuff and like
he looked all not like himself and like
different
cold-hearted and uh and we took him to
the hospital
and me and her like um
like literally stayed together since
then every day like every day we can
possibly like she's torn away and had
some breaks but like
you know i'm not even sure that like
those are
her all her intentions you know like i
think sometimes
just god has a way of splitting us up
and like
time out you know from because we go
through we've been through
a lot like there's probably 12 books we
could write just on
stuff since we've been in california
yeah just that
you guys find uh like some kind of
connection with the fact that you've
been through
you know you went through a divorce tina
and you went through a tough childhood
you guys kind of i do not for me
though i do i see that but i
i think it's cool that you don't yeah
see like i did a lot of hiding
when i was growing up i was the middle
child i was the only girl
and uh i just always
tried to be the person that people
i thought needed me to be um
and that came from some i don't even
know where it came out of but i didn't
even really
notice how much it affected my everyday
life
until i met mike and then some of our
other friends but
um i played orchestra in high school or
actually school all through school um
as long as i could i you know i'm a
nurse i did swimming for a little while
like
everything that i did youth group at
church i was always at church
i can say that i was never truly happy
doing any of it but i did it and i did
it to my
the best of my abilities and i succeeded
in most of it
but i just always felt like i wasn't
able to just like say here here i am
this is me
and it's nothing that it's not like my
family did anything wrong to make me
feel like that but
um i remember at the end of my marriage
feeling like the odd duck like i didn't
care about fitting in and keeping up
with everybody else's
like i don't care about your how much
your house costs or your car costs like
i want to know
like who you are and like i just like
couldn't meet anybody who i felt like i
had a real
like human connection with if all felt
like
plastic to me and that might have been
where i was in my life i think you're
like
with mike now no not at all like
as soon as i met him like i tried so
hard to not let him know who i was
man like i would lie to him about like
things that happened growing up i mean
like i would just
make up stupid [ __ ] just because i did
not want him to know that real me and he
always like he just saw straight through
it like he
did i remember i was like why is she
she's lying about this little stupid
stuff usually i wouldn't even deal with
that and i'd be like ah
like i'm not gonna be able to like be
with
you
i would have a hard time with that but
like i don't know when i met the day i
met her i felt like i was going to kill
myself that day too so it was just weird
i just was hung over
and was like i remember i was busting
tables at a job
then i waited tables at and like they
were telling me they don't need me
because of
my performance i was busting tables and
i was like
are you kidding me like i didn't think i
had that bad of a day like
i was like oh my god and like she was
the only bright spot
in in in my world at all that right then
and uh
but pain and suffering i think we do
have a common bond in that and i think
that
i think that even though she at times
doesn't want to admit to being
or doesn't admit to being an addict or
an alcoholic
like i think that that's our common bond
between us
is is that like we understand that part
of us
but what we yet have to do have
done together is shown that
we can have the common bond of recovery
too
like we although we don't have to be
totally abstinent
if we're not like if we're somehow
missing something and we can
still dabble and have a regular life
which i don't
know about that i'm pretty sure we can't
but um
but anyways my point to that was you
know i think
think that we're right now like to this
moment
um i think it's like a halfway point of
like where
where we start picking up the pieces and
start putting
like trying to get to my son's town
and and get presentable in front of
people to where i can
you know feel better about myself and
and not have
like cuts and he does that a lot torture
and
[ __ ] going on in my head i mean it's not
like it took me like two
two and a half years before i realized
some of the problems that he and i had
had together is
that he didn't feel like he was worthy
of anything basically but he definitely
didn't feel like he deserved to be with
me
and i kind of felt the same way
i was scared like when i walked into
their house like
they were going through a divorce i
happened to move she was moving from her
four-bedroom house to her um apartment
by herself after 13-year marriage
and i'm like oh [ __ ] dude this is sad
like like i felt bad and i was going
through some [ __ ] too
but um but i had been single for a
couple years
um so like dude we walked into our house
i see a lot of pictures of her kids and
like i see
like her cats running around kind of
taking over the place a little bit
and like i see the mess on the counter
and i could see an old bottle of liquor
and and like i just i just saw this
stuff and i was like damn dude like that
sucks i remember when i was in my house
and like
i was walking through it's like a
haunted house man is like [ __ ]
everything's making me cry like
you know like everything has a story
every piece of like furniture and [ __ ]
like
and um so i helped her move and move all
that stuff and i was just so scared
that like we were gonna lose everything
like even then like i didn't tell her
that but like
i don't know i lived in a homeless
shelter at the time and the only i think
the reason why i really jumped the gun
and tried to move in with her
was because she was she's such a nice
people pleaser
she like asked harry or told harry that
if you want you can crash at my house
like um i'm doing weekends
in jail or whatever like that's what she
was saying and um
and i just pictured harry getting with
her and i was like
nah let me let me try to rearrange that
because
i got that weird starting off a
relationship and stuff so
that's what happened and um what is your
drug today you're using
fentanyl fentanyl is pretty new as far
as like um
a choice of drug like i haven't been to
a place where you can get powdered print
all over
before this so uh before it was like
those blue
um the blues the 30s
i pressed up fentanyl they look like oxy
30s
roxies but they're actually fentanyl
i did those before but anyways my point
to that was uh
fentanyl nice and tina what are you
using
um about the same although there for a
while i was a little heavier on the
fentanyl and i've backed off on it now
it's scared
it's a little too scary um
but yeah fentanyl and ice
how would you compare your happiness
today
to what it was maybe five ten years ago
do you know
man it's crazy because i'm a lot happier
with who i am and a lot
happier with like the way i see the
world today than that
before the people that i've met out you
know on the street
and like mike and then
just it's amazing how like
honest they are with who they are like
this is who i am this is where i'm at
and take it or leave it but here i am
and i was so not used to that that it
was like
a blessing to be able to be around
people like that
like just take me or leave me but this
is me
and uh it's
i feel very happy and i'm very happy to
be out here with him still
yeah i really i really need to uh
get get some some progress going so i
can
make her feel better about being with me
and and
i say that because i see myself in her
too like um
like a people pleaser would speak i just
said to make her happy you know like
i want i want her to be happy but i'm
not like
i'm not sure how to make myself happy
like you know i like it or even care
about it
but i'm so selfish too at the same time
so it's like just weird
and and i don't want it to get worse but
i think that
we're pretty aware of what our problems
are now
um so we just have
yet to to uh really go full
force into the other direction i've been
really stubborn
um not giving up my advices because
of my reasons i have reasons like
i feel like people force me to do stuff
a lot in like
in different ways slick ways um and
and i feel like it's it's robbing me of
my experience in life man
like it's it's it's also prolonging it
but i'm the one prolonging it
i'm saying that i'm labeling that as
that
and so i'm i'm the one that's being
stubborn and using that as an excuse to
prolong my
mind but living in a tent on the
sidewalk is okay
to be honest with you like um living in
recovery
had showed me how to use acceptance
almost overly so you know what i mean
um like acceptance is the answer to all
my problems right there's that
and then uh also if you want to have a
wife though you should
should probably think about that
statement a little bit because you need
money too
you know and if you want to have some
some kids you should have money too
you i can accept that i can be broken
and i can accept a lot and be very
peaceful
because of calling jedi mind tricks or
whatever but like
it's acceptance it's it's just walking
through the day not labeling things
and i can do that until i'm i'm homeless
and i'm
would i want to do it without drugs like
nah i don't think so i think i would
have probably
like got a new shell if i was that
lobster that hadn't needed a bigger
shell
and then i was using something to cover
up the pain
to feel that i have a small shell you
know i probably would have changed
shells by now
and grown as a person and um
and got out of this rut instead of
furnishing it so i think i think uh
i kind of side checked that answer a
little bit but
yeah i think um i think i'm better with
living in a tent on the sidewalk than
she probably wants to be or maybe even
maybe i'm lying about that and don't
even realize what i'm saying
what would you say the most important
lesson you guys have learned
[Music]
um what would you say most important
lesson
i i know i know mine you want to go
first yeah
i've been learning it lately and it's
about it's about um
it's about priorities and like um
getting
like never letting her like get go
as far as like out of my sight if i'm
protecting her but like
really what it boils down to i won't
even be in that position if i got my
priorities straight
like i i don't i think like if i have
you know
god family and and like and me or
whatever
recovery whatever how you want to put it
in order
and i act that way in my actions because
i can say it
if i tell her i love you and my actions
don't say i love you
then that's that's that's the best i can
do
so like really
don't take her for granted don't take
anything for granted like my son
and this and that like what's ripping me
from that
you know so like i gotta structure my
priorities
tina what would you say most important
lesson you've heard
um taking responsibility isn't always
just about
talent like saying i'm taking
responsibility for my actions or
like this is you know it's my fault you
know um
it means a lot more than that because
you can be
response you can think you're taking
responsibility for your actions but
holding a lot of grudges against people
and a lot of hatred and like resentment
that you don't even know about um when
in reality
like you you know you're where you're at
because you're there
and you can just deal with it or just
continue being angry and
you know making choices that are going
to like he says delay the suffering but
um
if you just let it go and realize you
know i am where i am because
that's where god has me now
and that's what god wanted me to go
through and you know it's because of all
this
that you know i'm where i'm at now it's
a lot
it makes the outlook seem not so
dim because you realize you know like
my whole future
could have been just like continuing to
stack on these resentment and pain and
suffering that you didn't know about but
then you get here on the street
you're brought so low to where you
you're broken
and you kind of open your eyes and
realize like you know i'm not even mad
at them
you know i just need to let that go and
be okay with me
and he you know and move on from it and
it's kind of amazing how much relief you
get from that
i mean it sounds simple but it's not
because you can say you gotta like be
broken and get to the bottom of the
barrel you know before you can
recover but it's very easy to say
but sometimes the lowest point that
you're at
you think there's no worse it can get
worse
oh it does all right all right mike and
tina thank you so much for sharing your
story
all right i wish you guys the best of
luck out there on the street thank you
thank you very much
you